[Music]
you have a terrific woodshop you you're
great at building furniture beautiful
stuff this man's great woodworker are
you building anything of note I'm told
that you might have you might have
brought something for us today well it
yeah we we have a few young woodworkers
at the shop and we have an online store
called Offerman wood shop calm and
Christmastime has become a big deal
around the shop
our main seller in recent years has been
the Offerman wood shop mustache comb
which actually I think and you can get
you can get them customized we've
brought a couple bye beautiful thank you
great all you have to do is grow a
little more of a mustache and you'll be
ready to rake that fine hand oiled
walnut through it I got
and II and no no no no no we don't want
to know about that although the you
brought us something else this year we
have a new item you made the Offerman
woodshop kazoo has been taking the
country by storm one of our young guys
and I met Micucci created this and makes
them all by hand got how to make a kazoo
that says that you got it
that's the noise I was making earlier in
the show wasn't it yeah you could you
could accompany the human menorah
perhaps with the dreidel song on kazoo
do the dreidel song through this as the
human menorah walks through just a
thought I would never do anything so
sacrilegious